私には言う権利がないんだけど
皆様話し合って コピーしてもらっても構いません
テキストにもそれなりのチャートが書いてあるんです
そのチャートを見たらわかると思います
じゃあ今日 今日の勉強はこういう勉強ではなくて
この次の心所の勉強です
心所 で 徐々にこのパーリ語の言葉自体が慣った方がやりやすいってやりやすいんです
心所はチェットシカで読む
チェットシカ チェットシカ
で あの日本語の心所のそんなに意味が合ってる言葉ではありません
だからあのそれなりの言葉もないんです
はい じゃあ説明に入ります
心っていうのは このたった一つの働きで
そんなに分かりにくい大胆なことじゃないんです
私たちは生きているものっていうと
それは単なる心という働きなんです
だから 物体と生命体の区別は心でするもんなんです
ですから 誰でも知ってるんです
耳澄めたらこれ生きてるんだとわかるでしょうに
死んじゃったら死んでるんだとわかるでしょうに
そこで生きてるか死んでるかって
どこに区別するかというと
心があるかないかということで
我々はそれに心って言わないだけのことで
植物以外は死んじゃったらすぐわかるでしょ
例えばミミズが動いてるんだから生きてるんだと言っても
動くことだけで我々生きてるとは言うわけじゃないんですね
なんかどこかで感覚で生きてるんだと
まだ命があるんだと という
植物の場合はちょっと
死にくい いつ死ぬか 生物の場合は瞬時にそれするな
死んだと 瞬時にわかるんです
だから物理学だけ中心にしているんだから
医者にとっては人が死んだという判断は結構難しいんです
でも どんな人間でも とても簡単に人がもう死んなくなったっていうことがわかるんですよ
お医者さんがまあ そんな簡単にわからないんです
日本の医者だったら心臓が止まってるかないかと
ヨーロッパの医者だったら脳が働いてるかないかと
そこまで数字で 取らなくちゃいけないんです
でも我々はただ心が止まっただけで
人が死んだとも言わないし
もうなんとか頑張って生き返ってもらおうと思っちゃうし
だからまあ今わからないのは
この何ですって この機械入れちゃってね
人の体 物体を動かしているんだから
まあなんかちょっとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
生きてるかないかってことは
植物にしても生かされているんだから
そこは私もわからないんです
植物 人間には心があるかないかとは
だから脳死は死か 心臓停止死かっていうのは死かどっちかとわかるもんじゃないんです
一つ言えるのは 心臓停止だけは死じゃないんだということだけは言えるんです
それは誤解だと だから問題は心臓が停止してすぐ体に栄養が行かなくなっちゃいますから
すぐ死ぬ だから心臓 心臓停止っていうのは死の原因になるだけであって
死そのものではないんです
もしかすると脳細胞死んだらもう死んだかもしれません
でもそれもわからないんですね
どっちが死か で わかりません
我々のは瞬時に瞬間瞬間物質入れ替えないと
もう命っていうのはすぐ消えるもんなんですよ
そうに生きてるんだだからって言うんだけど
ずっと一秒も止まらず新しい物質入れ替えないと
機械とは違うんですね
機械はもうエネルギーあげないで一応瓶の袋に入れて置いとくだけで後で動くんだけど
体はそんなわけにはいかない
瞬時に栄養という物質を与えてあげなくちゃいけない
空気を与えてあげなくちゃいけない
これ 1 分間でも止まっちゃったらもう死んじゃう
だから心臓が停止しちゃったら
まあすぐ全部死んじゃう
それでも心臓停止しちゃったら
いろいろ心臓マッサージやら電気ショックやらいろんなことをして
また動かしてもらうでしょ
ということは 心臓停止した人が死んでいなかったということなんです
まあとにかく 一般的に物体と生命体を区別するのは
仏教から言えば心で区別するんです
心が活動しているものには生命体という心が活動してしてないものには物体という
そういうふうに安全 安全な定義を作らなくちゃいけない
だから大胆な判断にはいってはいけない
例えば植物は生命体かないかとかね
いえ 生命体じゃないとかあると
そんなのわからないんです
椅子はどうですか？とか
まあ我々の知識では物体であって
でも椅子に意識があるかないか我々わかりませんからね
一応生きているものを見たら
あ 生きているんだということはわかります
人間見たら この人は生きているんだと
死んでいるんだという人は一人もいないんだから
ということは 私たちは心をいつでもわかっているんですね
心っていうものは 心はわからないとそれは嘘なんです
心というものは簡単にわかるものということをところまで言っておきたい
それから見えるということも心であります
聞こえるということも心であります
当たり前ですね 味わえる
味わえる そういうことも今とても聞こえるでしょう
えっと だいたい我々はそういうふうに心というものを知っている
それで心はただこの生きているというぐらいのことで
生きてるということは認識するということ
外界 外の世界 この何か難しそうに聞こえますけど
つまらなそうに聞いてます
それは仏教だけにおいてはすごい大事な哲学なんです
このみんな尊い命 尊い命と馬鹿げた話しているんだから
こういう定義は大変あの
真剣に考えて言ってる定義なんです
全く間違わないようにと
この定義ぐらいでも理解すると
仏教の世界もわかるんです
ものすごく科学的に冷静に見ているんだから
感情的に見てないんです
例えばキリスト教見たらただの感情の塊でしょ
仏教はそれよりもものすごく反対の感情の主観的なことで
苦しみの元なんですね
たとえ神様愛していたっても
それは愛という感情だから
感情で物事がわかるわけじゃないんだ
感情で見てるんだから
人種差別やらいろんなものあるんじゃないですか
選ばれた人間とかああだこうだとか
我々は生き物を生き物かそうでないかと見ているんだから
もう差別はあえる余地がないんです
ミミズは生き物であって
私は生き物であって同じですよと
そこに心が働いているんだと
人間が優れているんだっていうのはもう冗談じゃないんです
あんな話は だから間違ってるし
言ってほしいのは人間が違うんだと
ミミズとは と言えば正しいんだけどね
それは私と皆さんは違います
5年前の私と5年後今の私
また違うし 5年後の私
また違うし 無常ですからね
ですから 違いますということは
ディファレンスということはいいんだけどね
優れているんだとか優れてないんだとかね
そういうのは無知の営みという言葉で
仏教では使わないんです
差はあるんだけど 差別化ない
差があったって別にどうってことないんだから
じゃあまあとにかく心はそういうことで生きているということで
そうすると我々にとってもちょっと問題が生まれる
ということかというと
悲しくなったり 楽しくなったり
つまらなくなったり 眠くなったり
活発になったり いろんな変化あるんですね
それが生き物の変化なんですね
聞いたり見たりする その働きはお互いに違うんですね
ただ 心は一つであるならば
一つの働きであるならば
その違いはどうやって説明するかということと問題になってくる
それで知恵と知覚というものの存在が
知恵と知覚という現象の在り方が見えてくるんですね
で まああの そのすぐわかりやすくするために
こことこういうところから始めましょう
私はこの心は水 水に例えるんです
水 水はどこにあっても全く同じもの
差はない 水は水です  H2Oです
でも私たちにはいろんな水があるんです
井戸水もありまして 海の水もありますし
塩水もあります ミネラルウォーターもあります
お茶やら紅茶やらコーヒーやら
そういう液体もあるし
でも どんな飲み物にしても基本は水なんです
水でないと飲み物というものになりかねない
体の中にもいろんな液体あるんですね
でも基本は 90%以上は全部水なんですね
血液を見たっても 血液あるんだと言ったっても
90%以上は水 そこで血液と唾液は違う
血液と涙がまた違う 血液と我々飲んでいる紅茶は違うんですね
色は同じだからといって同じものじゃないんです
血液とワインはまた違う
違うのはいいんだけど
水全く同じ じゃあなんでその例え使うかというと
何違いますか？と なんでミネラルウォーターと水道水が違うと私たちは言うんですか？なぜ海から取った水と水道から取った水はもう違いますと言うんですかね
そこでわかるのは 水は同じです
水に溶けているものは違う
水の中に溶けているもの
水の中に溶けているものは違うんだから
液体は自分の差を 自分のアイデンティティを作っているんです
井戸水は飲める 海水は飲めない
色は似ているんだけど
ワインは飲める 血液は飲めない
飲めないか 飲みたくないかどっち
それどこで我々その差別するんですかね？水で差別するんですかね？水で差別するわけじゃないんです
水の中に入っているものにとことから
その区別 差別判断するんです
例えば汚れてる水だから飲まないんだと言うでしょ
水だから飲まないんじゃなくて
汚れてるんだから飲まない
で ここの差別 区別と区別も
その心に溶けているものによって変わるんです
その心に溶けているものは心祖と呼ぶんです
ですから 水は液体はどこから取っても何か溶けてるんですよ
何も溶けてない純粋な百パーセントの H2O の液体はないんです
たとえ四十億円の古い水をね
南極 北極から取って持ってきても
その中に何か溶けているんです
ですから 我々は水だと言っても
水に何か溶けている 同じ心だといっても
その心に心臓が溶けているんです
だから我々はその差が感じちゃうんです
水に何でも溶けるような感じで
心にも溶けるような心臓がいろいろあるんです
そこで私は今楽しがっているんだというと
その生き物で何か認識しているんです
楽しいって認識 その心に何か溶けているんです
私は今腹が立っているんだと
腹が立っているんだという時と
楽しが楽しいんだという時の心は随分違うんです
なぜ違うかというと 心に溶けているものが違うんです
腹が立っていると その心に怒りが溶けている
楽しがっていると 他のものが溶けている
ですから 私は眠いんだ
つまらないんだ で 元気じゃないんだ
落ち込んで落ち込んでいるんだとか
舞い上がっているんだとか
いつでも我々は自分のことを言う
その時その時 心に違う違うものが溶けているんです
そういうことで いろんな心があるように感じる
だから心にはいろんなものを溶けたりはします
そこで何でも溶けるんだからといって
無差別に何でも溶けるわけじゃない
水と同じなんです 水に何でも溶けますけど
何でも無差別に溶けるわけ
わけじゃないんです それなりの法則があるんです
例えば 水に塩は溶けますけど
溶ける量が決まってるんです
そこで我々は水の代わりに紅茶を持ってきます
それで紅茶に塩を入れると
そうすると 紅茶に溶ける塩の量と普通の水に溶ける量
塩の量がまた違う ある法則があるんです
水と同じです 例えば あるものは冷たい水でと溶ける
あるものはお湯で溶けるという風にもありますね
あるものは部屋の温度で溶ける
と そのように心にもその心を持ってる状態によって溶ける心相が変わる
それで一緒に溶けるものと一緒に全然ならないものもまたあるんです
その勉強は一番大事なんです
心だけの勉強は何の役にも立たないんです
心の次元 これこれありますよと言っても
それは何の役にも立たない
心相の勉強はすごく大事なんです
だから我々の問題は心の問題ではなくて
心に何が入っているかということ問題なんです
心に怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ入ってる人は
我々はすごく良くない人だと思ったりするし
心に愛やら優しさやら人のことを心配することやら
そういうものを溶けてる場合はいい人だと言ってるし
生き物には変わりはない
その生き物のこの心の中に何が溶けてるかということによって
我々は善人か悪人の区別する
その点で我々は動物と人間の区別できる
その点で一人一人の人々の間にも区別できる
だから 嫉妬深い人がいて
優しい人がいると すぐ怒る人がいて
ものすごい笑顔でニコニコしてる人がいると
性格があるんですね この性格っていうのは
大体どんな心相がその人の心によく溶けやすいんですか？ということは性格なんですね
よく怒り 溶けやすい人の場合は
怒りっぽい性格だというし
いつでも眠気ばっかりで寝たばっかりだったら
そういう心相が溶ける場合は怠け者だと言ったりする
だから落ち着きがない人とか
怒りっぽい人とか 欲深い人
嫉妬深い人とか 鈍感な人とか敏感な人とかいうのは
その心に何が溶けやすいかということです
溶けやすい心相は性格なんです
だから他の心相を解けませんかと
そうでもない 私は怒りっぽいだからしょうがない
怒りしか解けませんよと
愛情なんかは解けるわけないんです
って言わない ただ たまに怒りっぽい人もすごい愛情作ったりはする
でもすぐそれ消えてまた怒りに戻ると
それぐらいの差なんですね
で 私たちは言うのは こういう悪い心相が溶けやすい人は訓練していい心相
心相を溶けるようにしなさいと
だから怒りっぽい人でも
ずっと慈悲の気持ちで
強引にでも慈悲の気持ち作っちゃうと
それを慣れてしまって
怒りが溶けにくくなっちゃう
それで性格は変わるんです
ですから 頑張れば鈍感な人にも敏感になれるし
無知な人にも知識のある人になれるし
人のことわからないのはそういうわけなんですよ
今はいい人ですけど年先どんな人になるかわからないんですね
年先じゃないんですよ
ちょっと一瞬の瞬間の先どうなるかわからないんです
どんな心相溶けるかわからない
だから人の性格だけは証明書を出せませんね
日本でわかりませんだけど
自分の国ではヨーロッパの習慣でいつでもこの certificate of character という何か必要になっちゃうんです
日本語で言えば何ですか
certificate of 何ですか
character  人格診断診断書
だから証明書です 人格の証明書みたいなもの
だから仕事をどこかに行く場合は
いろんな経歴書ですから
なんとか出すでしょ それだけでは通らないんです
自分の人格についても何か証明書を出さなくちゃいけない
ヨーロッパでも例えばアメリカの大学なんかにファイルすると
それ付帯しているんです
で その場合は誰かから
例えば学校でその学校の先生
教頭先生とかね で そういう人がこういう人はこういうこういう性格の人だよと書いてくれるんです
それは別に悪いこと書きません
その人信頼できない人ですよなんて書きませんし
結局役に立ちませんし
で そこで今決まってるのは
この 向こうは宗教というのは日常生活の一部だから
その自分が属しているお寺か教会かそちらから証明書を書いてほしいと
そこで自分のお寺だったら
信者さんの子供たちが仕事にどこかに行く場合は
三冊手に入れて証明書を書いてくると
お寺で何を書いてあげればいいんですか？だから一番いい人格の証明書を書いたけど
あれ読んで何を理解するかわかりませんだけど
ですから 人の人格っていうのはもう判断できないもんなんです
すぐ変わってしまう 環境によって
それは心にどんなものが溶けるかという現象
そういうもので決めるんです
ですから 心は水と水のごとく
何のもいいも悪いも何もない
その心に怒りが溶けたら怒ってる人になる
その心に慈しみの感情が溶けちゃったら
慈しみの人に優しい人になる
だから一人の人にたまに怒りっぽくなったり
たまに嫉妬したり たまにのたんだり
たまに大変慈しみな心行動心で行動したりする
そういうどっちでもできるんです
じゃあこれから これは一番大事なことでしょ
心というそのものよりは我々にとって
ただ生きているっていうことはそんなに大事なものではなくて
どう生きているかっていうことは大事なポイントで
どう生きるべきかということは大事なポイントで
どうでも生きているんだから
食べても食べなくても
寝ても起きていたっても
死ぬまでは そこは大変なことじゃないんですよ
生きていますよ 問題はどのように生きていますかと
どのように生きるべきかということ
ですから 我々に大変必要なのは心祖の問題
心っていうのはそんなに気にしなくてもいい
今まで長い間勉強してきたのは
まあ最近気にしない 長い時間かけて心の分析
心祖は５２種にあるんです
だから仏教のありがたいところはそういうふうにこの
わ まとめてくれてるんですよ
我々に聞けば あなた方が持っているすべての感情
リストしてください リストできますかね
どんな心理学者でも 人間に持てる人間が現れるすべての感情はこれぐらいですよとリスト作れますかね
作れませんと思います
そんな心知るわけじゃないんだから
例えば人は怒るのを見て怒りがありますよと言っても
怒りにもいろいろあるんだから
欲と言ったっていろいろあるんですから
そこですごく科学的に厳密にこのアトムですか
これを一番分けて分けて分けて
基本的にこれぐらいありましたというと
仏教では五十二種類の心想があるんだと
で この心想の特色 これまず覚えておきましょう
心想っていうのは あの
これ今心臓の説明しましたから
この心臓の代わりに何か適当な言葉ありますかね
チータ斯界の場合は 心の中身みたいなもんなんです
心の中身という意味なんですね
だから心想って心の中五十二あります
特色は心と一緒に生まれる
一緒に消える 心と一緒に生まれる
一緒に消える それから心と同じ対象をとる
心と同じ場所に生まれる
場所も同じ 生まれる場所
それぐらいです それはあんまり難しくないんです
一つの例を見るとわかります
例えば私は壁を見る 壁に絵あると考えましょう
壁に絵をかけています
私はその絵を見る 見るということは心ですね
目で見ると そこでその絵について感情が生まれるでしょう
だから感情も見る時は絵は対象であって
その絵について綺麗か綺麗じゃないか
面白いか面白くないかという感情が生まれる
ですから対象は同じ それで見ると同時に感情が生まれるでしょ
目を開けて絵を見た 見た瞬間で感情も生まれてるんです
一緒に だから心と一緒に生まれる
そこで絵を見ないようにしたから
もうあの感情消えるんです
で 心で一緒に消える 心と一緒に生まれて
一緒に消えて 同じ対象をとる
同じ場所に生まれるということは
見る場合は目で見るんだから
心想も目に生まれるんです
聞く場合は耳で聞いてるんだから
心想も耳に基づいて生まれるんです
それだけのことで終わりです
次に心想は一つ一つ何でしょうかと説明しなくちゃいけない
一番最初に出てくるのはこの心想なんです
サッバチッタサダーラナというんです
聞こえるんだ サッバチッタサダーラナ
サッバチッタサダーラナ
心想は七つあるんです
サッバっていうのはすべて
オール 一切 チッタっていうのは心
一切の心ということで
サダーラナっていうのは共通というか
顧問というか 共通 いわゆるどんな心にも必ずしも生まれる心所が七つあります
また 他の立場で言うならば
心に解ける最低の心所なんですね
最低と言うんですか 最初の最低限の心所なんです
それぐらい解けていないと心というものは生まれません
この七つはないとそこに心はないんです
で テキストの名前は今日
今日一切心所 心所 心所ですね
で リストで書くならば
パーリ語だったらこういうものなんですね
パッサ レペナ パンニャ
その時はどこにでも自分事実のテキストが大事なことですから
マヌスカラの方に まあそれはあの
まあパッサラさんにはチェタンガ八十四でマヌスカラっていうのは出て
あんまりこのめんどくさくない心所なんですね
どうせ生まれるものだからね
どんな心にも では説明します
それから今日一切心所の一番目はパッサと読むんです
パッサは コンタクト意味なんです
触れるという意味なんで
触という漢字書くんでしょうね
もしかすると 触れるというコンタクト
そこで触れるということは
心が何か対象と対象に触れる対象
何かの対象とコンタクトを取る
コンタクトを取らないと認識が生まれないんです
いわゆる生き物が何かとコンタクトを取る
それをパッサと呼ぶんです
生き物っていうのは外の世界とコンタクトを取ることだから
認識っていうのはそういうことだから
そこってどういうことかというと
目には目が光とコンタクトする
耳は音とコンタクトする
鼻は香りとコンタクトする
舌が味とコンタクトする
体がいろんな感覚と いろんなものと触れるということでコンタクトする
心がいろんな現象とコンタクトする
そこら辺ちょっとわかりにくいだけで
眼耳鼻舌身と同じことなんですね
体に何か触れたら我々はそれを知るんですね
あ 触れますと それでパッサと呼ぶんです
触と読むんですね 触れたんだから知ってるんです
で もう何のことないことなんです
でも生命の基本なんです
生命というならば 何かとコンタクトする
何かに触れる それによって認識が生まれる
そこで我々いうのは 体を 6つに分けて
眼耳鼻舌身意に分けて
その 6つの方向に 6つの種類の情報がコンタクトする
それ以上はなしと で 瞑想するときは
このパッサというところはよく理解してもらうんです
ヴィパッサナーでは 触れるということ
そこ大変大事なこと なぜならば
認識はそこから始まりますから
触れたこと うーん まあ分けたければ 6種類のパッサがあるんですね
目に触れること 耳に耳に触れること
鼻に触れること 舌に触れること
体に触れることと 意識に触れることと
いろんな概念 考えるときも何かについて考えてるでしょ
その時ちゃんと対象があるんです
心の中で触れて反応を起こして考えちゃうんです
ですから 分けたければ 6種類のパッサがあります 6
種類の触があります 分けなくてもいいんです
単なる触れることですよ
仏教で違うところは このコンタクトを取るものは永遠だのこうだの言うだけで
我々は証明ないものは言うなってことで
私たちってのは触れるものはずっと流れていくんだってことだけ
ことは流れていって だから触がたくさん生まれる
考え方もずっと流れていくんです
何か永遠な変化しないものに触れたわけじゃないんですね
触れたら一つの認識が生まれるだけで
また 2度 2番目の認識が生まれないんだから
だから永遠というものとはコンタクトできないんです
あるかないかもしれないし
まあ因果法則によってあるわけじゃないし
じゃあパッサはだいたいこれぐらいでわかると思います
2番目はヴェーダナー
ヴェーダナーについて前もしましたね
ヴェーダナーっていうのは触れたことを感じる
感じるということ 受だけでパーリ語だったら
仏教の漢字だったら受だけで結構です
分かりますね で 耳に何か触れたら
耳で何か感じる 体に触れたら体に感じる
触れても感じなきゃそこで認識が生まれません
それは我々にとっては問題にはならないんです
光にしてもいろいろ光あるでしょうに
我々はそれは知らないんです
知らないんだから それは問題にはならない
赤外線だから煩悩が生まれたとか
人と喧嘩しましたとか
そういうことはないんだから
目に入る光にとって感じるんだから
いろいろ問題が生まれるんです